Assertions are an important enough topic
that we're going to want to cover them separately.
What an assertion is is an executable check
for a property that must be true of your code.
For the square root example that we have been using,
we're defining a function called "sqrt,"
which takes an argument.
We're going to use that argument to compute our result,
and here we're going to assert that the result is greater
than or equal to zero.
So let's return to the square root example we've been using.
Here we're going to define a Python function called
sqrt, which takes an argument.
There's going to be some code at the top which computes the result
And now what we're going to assume is that if the
argument to the square root was negative--this bailed
out with some sort of exception--so if we reach
this line in the code, then we successfully computed
a square root result, and what we're going to do
is assert that that result is greater than or equal to 0 and then return it.
Why did we assert that the square root was always greater than or equal to 0?
Because we know, by definition, our square root function
is returning the positive square root of its argument.
At this point in the code, we know that
we must've computed a positive number.
So it's good to go ahead and assert that.
So let's look at some basic guidelines for
putting assertions into code.
The first rule is that assertions are not for error handling.
So, for example, it would've been a mistake
at the beginning of this routine probably
to assert that (arg) was greater than or equal to 0.
That would reflect a condition that we want to
handle with an exception--
that is to say with Python's established error handling mechanism--
and not with an assertion.
The assertion that we put into the code asserts the
result of our logic that we wrote as seen.
It's not asserting something about
the behavior of some other entity in the program.
That would generally be more in the domain of error checking.
Rule 2--and this is really important--
is never make assertion calls that have side effects.
An example of a side affecting assertion would be
asserting that a function foo returns the value of 0
but where foo changes the value of global variable.
And the problem with side effects and assertions are
when we turn on optimization in Python,
it's going to drop all of the assertions in our program.
So what we're going to have is a program
which happens to work correctly,
because the assertion changes a value
in some way that's needed.
But, on the other hand, when we turn on optimizations
and drop all of the asserts, then
the program's going to stop working.
And this makes the assertions worse than useless.
This is almost the worst possible thing you can do with an assertion
is have an assertion in your code that
changes the global state in some observable fashion.
So we definitely don't want to do this.
Now rule 3 is we don't want to put
silly assertions into our code.
And let me give an example.
So here we're asserting that 1 + 1 = 2
Now is it conceivable that in some Python program,
1 + 1 was not equal to 2?
Sure, it's conceivable if the Python interpreter is incredibly broken.
But, on the other hand, if the Python interpreter is
that broken, nothing is going to work.
Our program isn't going to run at all, so in any case,
there's no point whatsoever in doing a silly assertion like this.
The best assertions are those which check
a nontrivial property that could be wrong
but only if we actually made a mistake in our logic.
It's not something that could be wrong
if the user did something wrong,
and it's not something that's wrong that's
just completely silly to check.
Now I'm going to let you guys write some assertions.